just last year fossils of our species
were dated to 300,000 years ago much
earlier than anyone had suspected but
archeologists have struggled to find
many securely dated fossils and stone
tools from this critical time now a team
of researchers have uncovered a panoply
of evidence of early human behavior
dating back three hundred and twenty
thousand years ago to the middle Stone
Age from the use of sophisticated tools
to social networks and pigments this
toolkit emerged shortly after our
ancestors brains underwent a big surge
in size four hundred thousand years ago
and just before fossils that may be very
early members of our species appeared
the research is part of a multi-decade
project at sites on the allure gastly
basin of southern Kenya there the team
excavated some small carefully shaped
tools made of obsidian which is valued
for its sharpness the tools were made by
striking small blades and points often a
symmetrical core into a desired shape
and thickness this suggests complex
planning more than the earlier
relatively clunky large stone tools such
as the hand axe or scraper the opposite
ends of the points were sometimes
modified to allow them to be attached to
shafts this projectile technology is an
important step in the development of
hunting for fast and dangerous prey
these tools could be flung at a distance
with reduced danger to the hunter the
team analyzed the stone artifacts and
compared them to locations of obsidian
sources in Kenya they found that the
rocks must have been transported from as
far as 90 kilometres away farther than
individuals were likely to walk this
suggests that the rock for making stone
tools and other objects may have been
passed hand to hand in a network of
ancient humans such networks would have
required considerable social and
cognitive complexity this is the
earliest evidence of human social
networks to date just as remarkable was
the discovery of rocks used for
colouring one site had rocks streaked
with black manganese and other sites
revealed process
red ocher these pigments may have been
used to draw on people's bodies as a
form of symbolic identity if you have a
red streak on your forehead it signals
to others possibly hostile strangers
that you're the person they met with
before and that you're trustworthy so
why and how did these shifts and
behavior happen with middle Stone Age
hominids researchers examined a plethora
of evidence from the base and sediment
and found at the time in which these
individuals emerged was one of severe
resource and stability and episodes of
scarcity these ancient humans may have
expanded their social networks and
hunting skills as a means to survive
such unpredictable changing conditions
researchers have yet to uncover hominin
fossils from the Middle Stone Age at a
lore gastly but the tools tell us much
about their makers these new discoveries
provide strong support that some aspects
of modern behavior have deep roots and
emerged early in Africa then evolved
gradually over time
[Music]
you
you